The case was brought to Allen
Hynek by a man named Francis
Wall, who had been a private
first class in Korea during
the Korean War in 1951 where
his company was engaged
in hostilities, and they noticed
an object he described as kind
of like a Jack-o'-lantern
type maneuvering
where they were firing their
ordnance, their weapons.
And they got its attention.
So it starts to move
toward their position,
and they get permission
to fire on it,
and they're shooting it
with their M1 rifles.
And he says, to
Hynek, you could hear
the pinging sound on the
craft from their bullets.
It begins to hit them with this
kind of ray which burns them.
They get this uncomfortable
tingling sensation.
It's obviously affecting
them neurologically,
and they retreat, at
which point this object,
he says, just shoots up
into the sky and it's gone.
They get evacuated out of
their position a couple of days
later, and a lot
of these soldiers
had high white blood
cell counts, which
is symptomatic of an infection.
And then what he
said to Hynek was
that in the aftermath
of this a lot of them
had medical discharges and were
just sent home because they
couldn't function anymore.
I think those cases are very,
very difficult to explain away
where they've obviously
being irradiated
with some form of energy
scrambling their body.
And those have happened
before, and some of that
has happened in
connection with UFOs too.
RICHARD DOLAN: Presumably
this came to Hynek many years
later to the Center for UFO
studies in Evanston, Illinois
where he worked.
Private Wall, he's
the only person
to come forward with this
story, unfortunately,
so there's no corroboration.
According to what
he said, the Army
passed off the event
as war-induced trauma,
hallucinations,
that type of thing.
And given the controversial
nature of the subject,
it's understandable that both
scientists and even witnesses
are reluctant to come forward.
This was a terrifying
experience which medically
makes absolutely no sense.